ah is it okay to show these nipples but
they are having I don't think that's
okay for the video nipples
they're totally filters yeah they're
totally see-through
oh god this out yeah I found yeah
Oh God you can be naked what the [ __ ] oh
god what is that [ __ ] great like a
she has nice legs I got a say but that
honey
oh I'm female around the females too and
everything oh yeah my GPS
I thank you oh haha in traumatized that
is trauma man yeah too many penis no no
penis no penis you can see the penis no
I'm the females again oh god that money
on it what that [ __ ] those jiggly's oh
yes I barely hit the budget wait so we
already we're all together against the
Bates yeah we're all against one team
ago us you guys have a teacher low - all
the dudes wellness oh no no let's
restart
oh no you sure you that you choose it
when you log in uh-huh I'm a dude are
you doing oh hey oh I think that one I'm
glad they're here Candice Candice
oh [ __ ] what do you do is this the
collective I'm being shot here's the
collector I got a crystal a blue Casio
deliver it to the bin I got a delivery
to J recycling what a treat I bet it
yeah I love the jumping it's the
best-looking I think I did it well done
how do you like how the hell we're
losing this is so easy how do you roll
I'll be losing you double tap don't
float
yep double tap that [ __ ] don't let that
voice go I thank you like vampire wait
[ __ ] over there I gotta come over here
and shoot him save the day Oh Troy I got
yo help this once they get to me I'm
[ __ ]
where is he ever kill the collector I
tried Jesus but wasn't having it goddamn
it
he lose anyway I mean he kills a
collector yes best team ever
whoo look at fellas points just give me
some well no I seriously he's gonna
twerk ah eh you call that [ __ ]
God yeah that's good good that's some
hardcore [ __ ] twerking going on now I
like everything anybody since me it's
like can notice me senpai I'm like shut
up oh my god awesome fan art and
everything's I like sympa wait so you
actually noticed them but you don't
acknowledge to notice oh you're a buyer
or percent by guy you see no one is
talking about my ass hey uh who is so
round I know what a girl can i trace on
intial ginge they're coming for us
diving through my ass it's beautiful oh
she's acting to have an ass I covered
the screen keep staring at your anchor
his ass like all can I go yeah it's
beautiful dude that's how you play this
game game play oh is that [ __ ]
oh there ugh it was mine out oh no I got
burned
brutal man can ever live and we capture
it wait
hey where's their God I have so little
help look at me Oh John my lay like
missing yeah what the hell seriously god
same pony I wonder if my ass can be
missing or something oh [ __ ] a big boy
come on take it back guys come on it's
right hey man King Gaddy
yeah girl look at cigarette you get flat
that diving how dare they
how can they touch my beautiful bride
dive inside it I'm inside it yeah I live
here now gonna put up okay
I love really happens guys in real world
stop in feet-first actually just in case
you got to dive into love you gotta take
a leap of faith if we don't win we can't
upload this video I'm at the next point
you gave away to secret to all those
friends I just shove it into an abyss is
that the way we thank you God they keep
jumping and [ __ ] yeah they're really
hard to pin down they're gonna have got
it
nah we're losing to fake people yes we
are but the program to be good oh I got
it again or you can run they don't know
it we're not doing as well now they're
coming back oh my god
oh god I don't have my head anymore
that's this whole thing I find that's a
constant problem to me yeah I know
ah I can't make a sexy one you into air
they're not red
Barry : it would have been a
responsibility it would have been a
really bad one check it yeah now watch
this hey dance oh yeah yeah
don't shake it ah ah get to keep doing
it how do you again and again
actually bullet somebody in the evening
great sound effects then I'll have sound
no you do anything you should she should
be the sound of a butter butter butter
butter butter ping Dan survivor we're
doing regular camera-- make this out of
my ass cheeks please boom right share
yeah that's what I wanted I dropped my
blue that's beautiful
I can hear that sound as I run behind
you feud's we all can see you'll see
little browner mmm
makes me excited I know it does Ken I
know it does
Thanks I got that maybe it is Oh God
look at her outfit that's really slight
all right here I go motorboat
boy are you throwing up at the same time
yes cuz I'd do anything for that booty
mm-hmm so this happens in every single
game you guys play fake memories of a
mirror in prop hunt or something along
those lines I'm not quite sure why I
watch that every night before you go to
Maine
yeah and then I can't sleep because yeah
I can't go sleep a boner get this person
okay I like this in August you have one
you're all over like cuz it's not for
something you know what the heck what no
and like okay I'm honestly surprised you
haven't asked us more questions about
boners for the longest time that we've
known you I know you can break your
penis but I know you get snapping same
thing this is the B this is the video I
don't think it makes it like a cracking
snap it's more like it's our oh my god
yeah it's broke now it's really al oh
that hurt a little bit I guess I told
you not to move like that we can try
some new positions now I can knowledge
do that standing thing I always want to
try that I've seen the corners nah it'll
it's not gonna wear yet it seems like it
will whoa good never when I get this gun
it I have lit okay you guys need to stop
hey stop please whoa how do I twerk
how do i twerk tell me fast Chris h4j
take a little jiggle jiggle jiggle
jiggle jiggle jiggle
yeah sweet with my bag you like that you
like that you like when I shake a tease
yeah you
yeah yeah now the most disturbing moment
of sleep with me come and sleep with me
shut up and sleep with me come on why
don't you stick with me shut up and
sleep with me come and sleep